Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Espen Hammer. He's professor
of philosophy at Temple University, and today we're going
to talk about his book After the Death of
God Secularization as a Philosophical Challenge from Kent to
Nietzsche. So Dr. Hammer, welcome to the show. It's
a huge pleasure to everyone.
Thanks a lot for having me, Ricardo. So,
um, before we get into the sort of, uh,
philo philosophical history that you explore in the book
in terms of how particularly in the modern Western
tradition, uh, philosophers Have explored religious, religion and secularization.
Um, LET'S start perhaps with the definition here. So
what is secularization and what is the secularization thesis?
Yeah, that's a good question to start with. The
book is called After the Death of God, which
sounds very dramatic, but it is the short version
of what secularization actually is, secularization in the shortest.
Formulation possible is simply that God dies away and
becomes an incredible, uh, view. We no longer believe
in God and God doesn't play any role in
human life any longer. Um, I, uh, distinguish between
secularism and secularization.
OK, so, so tell us then about that distinction.
Yeah, secularism is a normative view, a form of
critique of religion which has its roots in the
Enlightenment. It's quite focused on belief and on trying
to undermine the credibility of belief in the divine
and the super sensible. And, uh, it's more or
less militant depending on the kinds of groups and
individuals you are looking at. Um. Then you have
a wide conception of secularization, which is usually taken
to be a sociological or historical term, and that
is the term that I am primarily interested in
in this book as a kind of framework for
what I do. I'm not personally a sociologist myself,
although I have studied sociology and history, but, uh,
I am a philosopher, but I am interested in.
Secularization as a framework for thinking about the philosophy
of religion in the post-Kantian tradition. Because I think
if you don't have this context, this sociological and
historical context of secularization. Then the philosophy of religion
in this tradition becomes More difficult to truly understand.
So The classics of sociology almost always talked about
secularization. People like Comte, Weber, Durham. Uh, AND in
the 20th century, people like Berger, for example, uh,
were interested in secularization as an aspect of modernization,
modernization being perhaps the most important theme in classical
sociology. What is it about modernity that sets it
apart from pre-modern social arrangements, right? And the classics
argued that religion and the loss of religion or
the weakening of religion. AKA secularization is absolutely central
to modernization. Um, SO, in some cases people even
almost equate modernization with secularization. So it's a very,
very important term in Max Weber, for example, the
most famous one. Who of these classics in sociology
who deal with sectarization. Disenchantment is the term for
secularization. Disenchantment is a process whereby the world becomes
more rationally masterable, you know, the spirits, the Super
sensible life that. Purportedly existed, especially in the medieval
mind, are dying away and uh Weber says that
with the rise of science and technology, you see
a new way of looking at the world. It
becomes rationally masterable. Technology becomes the expression of this
sense of the world as being rationally masterable, and
that means that the religious worldview becomes weakened. Then
you have people like Durkin, for example, who see
religion as losing its role socially. Over time. Starting
out from a mechanical form of solidarity in which
people are very, uh, beholden to some kind of
unified expression of authority. Which is given a kind
of, uh, well, in these traditional societies is given
a religious religious interpretation. Two modern societies that are
solidarity that whose solidarity is based more on formal
relations between people, laws, you know, contracts, all these
kinds of things that kind of unite people in
more formal ways in modernity and, uh, in these
kinds of societies, the traditional. Religious solidarity is then
being weakened. So Um, secularization is often presented as
a form of subtract subtraction. You start with a
religious worldview and then you kind of subtract from
that in a more or less linear fashion. Um,
They're often. Considered to be three fundamental dimensions of
secularization. Decline in belief, so people just simply fewer
and fewer people subscribe to religious tenets and beliefs.
Um, THAT'S what people often associate exclusively with secularization,
that people just stop believing. Mhm. In sociology in
the 20th century, it's more common to think of
secularization in terms of differentiation. And that means that
religious authority is Declining in ever more spheres of
society as society disengaged with religion, so politics, you
know, with the rise of liberalism or with Marxism
and so on and so forth just becomes less
and less religiously informed. Uh, SCIENCE, of course, in
modernity becomes less and less, and then of course
with the in the 17th and 18th century science
becomes completely disconnected to religion. Uh, ART and aesthetics
becomes less and less beholden to. Religion religion and
so on and so forth. So there's a differentiation
and re religion is left to its own sphere
as it were. This is a very common sociological
view of secularization. And then finally, you have privatization
of religion, that religion. Becomes more and more confined
to people's private lives. And phase becomes more and
more personal and to some extent a kind of
lifestyle choice that people adopt in. Certain cases and
for reasons that may seem flimsy and not very
authoritative, just like, you know, you decide to wear
Levi's jeans, um, it doesn't really, you know, it's
not because you, it's just because you happen to
like them and some friends of yours and wear
them and so on and so forth, it becomes
a lifestyle choice. That's the extreme version of privatization,
but the privatization was there already, I think from
the get-go in Protestantism with the, of course, with
the. Loss of the church's authority in Northern Europe.
And then you have uh questions of the drivers
of secularization and typically science. Industrialization, urbanization. Capitalism is
often considered to be a very important driver of
secularization because capitalism forces us to see ourselves as
Engaged in rational self-interest and rational self-interest is not
what certainly what Christianity has traditionally been encouraging people
to become an attitude that Christianity has been encouraging
people to take up. Um So religion is still
strong in various places, um, but in general I
think people see. Secularization as having made strong inroads,
certainly in European and also in American culture. Although
there are new forms of spirituality that may may
to some extent be difficult to Get hold of
and fully see because we may not have the
right definitions to understand what we're dealing with. So
I think there are many compensatory versions of uh
religion, but in general, I think especially in Northern
Europe. Um, ETHNIC secularization is very palpable and very
real. Mhm.
Uh, I, I mean, what would you say are
the main critiques that secularists and modernists over these
past few centuries, particularly the past couple of centuries,
have put forth, er, against religion?
Yeah, I think now you're addressing more of the
business about secular secularism as a kind of, you
know, set of belief, a set of attitudes to
religion, and, um, I think one important, uh, negative
attitude to religion has been that religion poses as
a false authority. It sometimes takes on very authoritarian
dimensions. And um people who are critical of religion
often tend to focus on the way in which
it has had too much power, perhaps on a
basis which is not really justifiable in areas such
as politics. Art pedagogy, for example. Um, AND that,
that has led In many cases to an oppressive
type of practice. And I think this brings us
to the second set of critiques that have been
launched against religion in the name of secularism, and
that is that religion actually can be quite morally
problematic, that it can be oppressive, it can be
at odds with modern desires for freedom and self-actualization,
especially in late capitalist consumerist societies. In which people
certainly don't want to be told what to consume,
how to consume things, what to do with their
lives, in which there's a very strong demand for
radical consumerist freedom, which is then radically at odds
with, uh, much religious doctrine. Certainly in the Judeo-Christian
West, but also very strongly in the Middle East
and. Also in Eastern societies, um. And then the
kind of critique that I think most people associate
with um. Secularism in the critical religion, which is
that it is really truly at odds with the
modern. Worldview, the, the scientific worldview. Mhm, um, THAT.
A religion is metaphysically unjustifiable. Because Rationally. Binding evidence
has to be ultimately the kinds of evidence that
we can have in science. And any appeal to
the super sensible is just not going to be
a reliable. Authority for belief, um, so faith. In
some super sensible divine form of life or authority
or agency is just epistemically unrespectable. This is the
kind of critique you find in the so-called new
atheists, people like Richard Dawkins, for example, who has
made this very famous. Who started out like launching
a very, very direct critique of religion some 1520
years ago, uh, became Had a lot of influence
for quite some time. Um, BUT I think gradually
some people have come to see that this form
of criticism may have some weaknesses, that religious faith
was never trying to compete with science. The belief
formation in religion just isn't. Analogous to belief formation
in science, that there's something deeply problematic to set
science and religion on a par like that and
just. You know, compare belief formation in science to
belief formation in. In religion, people that wanted to
defend religion have said, well, belief formation in religion
is much more like belief formation in For example,
You know, Personal relations. I love relations in which
someone falls in love and um what kind of
evidence do you have in this, in this regard?
I mean, uh, falling in love and being in
love uh it involves uncertainty. It involves sometimes agonizing
doubt, you know, does the other really reciprocate. Um,
Is my love worth it? Um, IS it worth
my time and emotional investment and so on and
so forth? Um, BELIEVING in God, I think you
can see in the church fathers and you can
see in the, certainly in the Christian tradition. Involves
agonizing, involves a lot of doubt. It's not aimed
at epistemic certainty except with some. Exceptions like rationalist
philosophy like eququinas, for example. If you really try
to establish some sort of proof of the existence
of God, then you lend yourself to criticism because
you lay the bar very highly of epistemic certainty.
You say, I can actually prove this with certainty.
Um, BUT I think most people who are religious
don't really pay attention to these kinds of religious.
Uh, PROOFS very much, and they're not very important
in religious life for most people.
Yes, and I mean, I, I am a, I'm
personally an atheist, but I'm not anti-theist. I'm I'm
not anti-religion in any way. I'm not a militant
atheist, and I, when it comes to, for example,
the new atheists, the, the two that are still
alive, Sam Harris and Richard Dawkins particularly. I mean,
I don't, I, I've never thought that they really
had a very strong case, er, I mean in
terms of their, even their claims that can be
tested and have been tested by scientists of religion,
anthropologists and others. I mean they are very weak
scientific claims scientifically. And also I mean when it
comes to, for example, criticizing religion in terms of
assuming that it is especially inducive to immoral behaviors,
for example, I mean, I also don't think that
religion is especially Prone to that, I think there
are, there are other domains of human life, of
human life like politics, for example, that can also
drive people toward immoral behaviors very easily. So, uh,
I, I mean, I never took the new atheist
movement too seriously, uh, scientifically, philosophically, and so on.
Um, I mean, but, but, uh, this, this is
a, a question that I think is very, uh,
interesting to explore and also very provocative, especially for,
uh, atheist people like myself. So,
uh, does
secularism actually
have
a theological origins?
Well, that is a very interesting question. It has
been debated, um, a lot and debates surrounding secularization
and secularism, whether these theological origins have reemerged in
much contemporary debate. Also in philosophy, which is interesting
for me since I am a philosopher and I'm
interested in, in these kinds of questions from, from
not just a historical point of view but also
from a philosophical point of view, understanding the genealogy
of central. Uh, TERMS that philosophers are used to
studying. Um, You have, there is a tradition of
holding that secularism and secularization have theological origins that
Goes way back, but. In modernity, I think we
often associate this with people like Nietzsche, Carl Schmidt.
Uh, Lowitz, German thinker, Hans Blumenberg. Um, AND certainly
most recently, Habermass, uh, who passed away just a
couple of weeks ago, but who in his very
late years, uh, wrote. A 2000 page. History of
philosophy and religion and trying to show the interconnection
between philosophy and religion or between faith, between um
knowledge and and faith, um, and I think it
is quite commonly accepted that our Western moral system
has grown out of Christianity. Like concepts like equality.
Dignity. Uh, PERSONAL freedom. Moral responsibility, they all seem
in different ways to stem from the idea that
we are all God's children in a certain way
that we are. We have come to this world
as Equally dignified in the eyes of God. Um,
Levitt is interesting because he argues that our, our,
much of our understanding of history is very shaped
by ideas of Providence, ideas of eschatology. Uh, THE
idea that history has some kind of direction. That
it is to some degree structured teleology that you
can see ends. Being operative in history, that history
has some sort of end state, which became very
important of course in certain versions of Marxism. Um,
YES, although these versions of Marxism have been criticized,
I think rightly so, um, for being too metaphysical,
but I think they certainly can be shown to
have some kind of origin in eschatological thinking, you
know, the idea that God has some sort of
plan for human history and that human history is
playing itself out according to this plan. Even though
the plan may be rough and allow for a
lot of mishaps and evil, unfortunate events. There is
some sort of deep meaning behind history, and many
people have read Hegel in this way that Hegel
is precisely the major modern philosopher of precisely this
view of history that history is. Divine in some
sense. You have, uh, Hans Blumenberg, who was an
interesting philosopher and intellectual historian in Germany and, uh,
in the second half of the 20th century. He
doesn't believe in translation. He doesn't believe that secular
concepts have been translated from religious concepts. The way
People like Schmidt and Levitt believe, but he does
believe that the modern worldview came into being as
a result of a certain kind of crisis. In
the medieval religious Christian worldview. Uh, HE argued that.
Um, The classical medieval worldview saw God as. Expressing
himself. In the order that we're able to find
in the world, in the universals, as these universals.
Dictate how everything in the universe. Is supposed to
develop and interconnect with all the processes in the
universe. There's a deep fundamental order to the universe
and God is in the universe working his way
through creation. This is basically the Aristotelian, uh, Christianity
that you see in people like Aquinas, for example.
Yeah, um, but. In the late medieval period, you
saw people worried that this is going to limit
God, this is going to constrain God too much
because he's going to constrain by, going to be
constrained by the order that he has created. He's
going to be stuck in this order. So how
can we argue for the Absolute power of God
on this view, he seems to be constrained by
his own order. So the novelist said, well, actually
he's, God is not limited by this order. Uh,
FOR God to be absolutely powerful, he has to
in a sense be outside this order. He may
have created it, but the world is playing itself
out independently of God's. Connection to the world, and
this created a lot of anxiety, the world suddenly
started to seem less guaranteed by some sort of
divine uh presence. Um, THE world started to look
contingent. It seems to open up for possibilities that
it could go in all sorts of directions. The
world could end tomorrow. What do I know? Um,
SO human beings would have to step in and
create order. In other words, threatening and chaotic universe.
This was the universe's view of modernity that. Human
beings step in and fill this emptiness. That was
left after God, so to speak, pulled out of
this order and this made Scientific curiosity possible and
ideas of human constitutional order as you find in
Kant, for example, and the whole idealist tradition that
somehow human beings constitute order in the world. Um,
THIS is also a way of thinking of secularization
and secularism as having theological origins. Even though there's
no translation from directly from the. RELIGIOUS order to
the Christian order. It's more a kind of leap
into. A form of emptiness that occurred as God
in a sense vacated creation in order to secure
his own. Infinite power. So these are fascinating ways
to see secularization as going way back in time
as having its origin deeply embedded in the Christian
and religious systems that. Preceded secularization. Right.
Uh, I wanted to ask you, uh, why is
it that you decided to focus in your book
on 19th century German philosophy specifically? I mean, is
it, uh, because, as a philosopher, you are more
familiar or you focus most of your work on
Philosophers from that tradition specifically, is it because you
think that the philosophers whose work we're going to
explore here are the ones with the critiques that
are most relevant to the topic you explore in
your book, or was it for some other reason?
Well, uh, it is certainly a tradition that I
feel reasonably familiar with, but I don't think that
was the main reason why I focused on Kant
and the aftermath of Kant's revolution in philosophy in
order to understand how philosophers responded to secularization. It
was mainly because These 19th century philosophers, as is
the case with many intellectuals in the 19th century
and many artists. Uh, ARE in a sense children
of the Enlightenment. The Enlightenment. I see the Enlightenment
as engaged in a lot of very epistemically oriented
critiques of religion, you know, people like Hume and
people like Diderot and so on, um. Criticized The
idea that we can have any kind of rational
belief in religion. That's very, very pronounced in Hume,
for example. Um So This is a form of
rational critique, and you may as a religious person
feel um. That that kind of critique is not
really hitting so hard because you weren't so interested
in some sort of rational critique in the first
rational view of religion in the first place, as
we talked about earlier, maybe your whole uh understanding
of religion is much more emotional. So When I
say that the 19th century intellectuals and artists and
philosophers are children of the Enlightenment, I mean children
of the Enlightenment in a very broad sense, not
just epistemically, but there's a strong sense in 19th
century culture and certainly European culture that Well, That
religion is in a crisis. Um, You see this
very strongly in the romanticism, which is a very,
very. Very, very clearly a 19th century, um. Uh,
MOVEMENT in, um. Both in philosophy and in the
arts, especially strong in poetry, of course. A sense
of a crisis of meaning, a crisis of orientation.
Um, YOU see this new bourgeoisie emerging in Europe,
which on the one hand is very, um, kind
of weathered to Techno scientific views of um. Of
progress and the like, but leaving on the other
hand, as a sense of emptiness, people just feel
that this new kind of life form just doesn't
offer the kind of meaning that the older religious
communities were able to, um, to offer. So, I'm
kind of thinking that many of these 19th century
intellectuals are starting to feel the crisis of religion.
Um, PERHAPS more emotionally and not just intellectually, they're
feeling this more as a crisis of meaning than
as a crisis of justification perhaps. Um, SO what
I do see in the Kantian post-Kantian tradition. Is
an interest both in critic criticizing religion because these
are, I mean they are after all philosophers, they
are interested in the rational claims of religion and
the extent to which religion can be seen rationally
and the ways in which religion may be seen
to fail, um. Being fully. Rational, but on the
other hand, they're also interested in rescuing certain dimensions
of religion, and that's why secularization in its social
garb is very important to me. I try to
understand secularization strongly in terms of how religion has
filled a specific kind of social role, has given
a people a sense of. Meaningful participation and solidarity.
And that with secularization that gradually becomes lost. You
see this very strongly, as I said with the
19th century bourgeoisie that sees itself in much more
individualistic terms than Previously And um this generates a
kind of crisis. Um, Which is different from the
merely um rational crisis, a crisis, as I said,
of meaning of social, social solidarity, and also a
crisis with regard to um what you might call.
Um, ASPIRATIONS to happiness. You know, what kind of
happiness is left for us as we keep using
all religious ways of thinking about fulfillment. Um, IS
happiness. Left to be just something like pleasure, does
it only have some sort of consumerist meaning? And
if so, is that very limited? Is it very
um. Contingent as it lacked the kind of deep
meaning that religion was offering in terms of its
understandings of salvation and bliss and so on, uh,
associated with happiness and of course. Faith itself was
always understood to offer a kind of fulfillment that
1 may see is in a crisis in the
19th century. So all these things I think are
playing in the 19th century intellectual responses to secularization.
There is a genuine sense of a more widespread
type of crisis than just the rational crisis that
you see in the Enlightenment.
Right, and so when thinking about the role of
religion, do you focus then mostly on its social
role? Is that it? Or do you also consider
perhaps some more effects that it has on individuals
like. For example, related to meaning related to, for
example, morality, related to, uh, even individual motivation, I
guess. Uh, I mean, how do you approach, uh,
how do you look at the role or roles
that religion plays?
And that's a, that's a very central question I
think to the project that I was embarking on
this, uh, in this book, um. I think one
thing that you see as religion is dying out.
In the ways that we have been talking about,
you see a certain kind of fragmentation. It's very
hard to see any kind of deeper unity. Um,
THIS unity may be the unity that you're feeling
in yourself, a kind of unity between your mind
and your, your body. But also a form of
unity between or between the rational and the emotional
parts of yourself. Uh, WITH secularization, the rational part
of yourself may seem to come apart and, um,
you may start to feel that the ends you
are able to set rationally. Um, MAY not speak
to you as an emotional being. This is quite
central to both Kant and Hegel that. There's a
kind of emotional deficit as society is expecting us
to behave more and more rationally. In order to
be a fully operative member of a rational kind
of techno-scientific society, we feel that we become more
and more split beings. Um, WE feel that our
whole emotional life becomes left out and you see
a kind of crisis in that culminating for, for
example in. The need for psychoanalysis, for example, which
kind of starts to address this lost dimension of
human life, the feelings, the desires, and so on
and so forth. We also a form of fragmentation
to do with, um, the, the relationship between individuals
and society, or the relationship between individuals and nature
in general, um, privatization, this new bourgeoisie feels, um.
Disconnected from uh. You know, communities in some kind
of deeper and more involving sense. It's about you
and your success or your failure, and, uh, you
have to deal with risk in a new way
in this new bourgeois capitalist society. Risk is individualized.
It's, it's more like, how do you cope with
the demands on you in terms of securing a
good education. Doing well on the market, getting the
right job and so on and so forth. In
pre-modern societies, risk was very often very collective. It
had to do with the whole community and the
whole community represented risk in terms of the community.
So if someone fell ill, it was sort of
a threat to the community and the community took
responsibility. Whereas in modernity, we're very, very individualized in
terms of our understanding of risk. And that also
relates to secularization because of course, in a more
religious worldview, risk is a more communal type of
commitment and experience. Um, So, um. I I see
in 19th century intellectual life a yearning for more
meaningful frameworks that can unite people. With themselves. To
become more fully united beings, but also beings who
can unite meaningfully with the community and with, with
nature, um, this also translates into ethics and moral
philosophy and being able to act morally in a
meaningful way, to be able to set oneself goals
as I was touching on that. Express my sense
of solidarity with older people. Not just acting rationally
on my own imperatives, but acting morally such as
to feel at home with my community. To act
such as to receive recognition from all the people.
In the pre-modern religious society, there were ways to
act. Morally right that. We obviously receiving recognition from
the community. You know, there were staked out paths
that the religious community had for you, and education
was very tailored to understanding what the right path
of life was for you. Ultimately, right, that right
path of for the individual was the path of
God's will for the individual, and God's will was
never to isolate the individual from the community. But
to see yourself as acting meaningfully within God's own
community. So all this has kind of like deep
implications both for your self-understanding. Um, As more than
just irrational, self-interested, um. Maximizer of goods and also
for your sense of connection and meaning. There is
a deep sense of nihilism in 19th century intellectual
life, a sense of, well, I mean, what are
actually the deepest values of life. Perhaps with the
death of God we feel a real sense of
confusion. This becomes very dramatically expressed in Nietzsche, of
course, he says, you know. In the 125th aphorism
of the gay science, you have. You have this
crazy man who runs into the um. Village and
cries, you know, God is dead, uh, we are
now faced with absolute confusion. Absolute confusion about what
really counts in life, what really matters in life,
and what are the Highest values as Nietzsche expresses
it.
Uh, SO do you think that there's good enough
evidence, and of course all of the studies related
to this have some limitations to them, but do
you think that there's, uh, good enough evidence that
religion, uh, across the globe is on the decline
or could even go extinct, at some point in
the future?
Yeah, I mean, I think for this question we
have to distinguish between sociological predictions, which are always
extremely unreliable, and, uh, secularism as a more normative
orientation. I mean, I think sociologists today don't really
think that it's likely that religion will more or
less go away. It was predicted that the secularization
thesis predicted that it would go away, that modernization
would just continue to just. Conducted on felt on
religion leading up to some point in the more
or less near future, many people believed in the
mid or early 20th century in which religion would
just disappear. Um, THAT has not been the case.
Religion has taken new forms, it has become much
more individualistic. Um, THERE'S fragmentation and so on and
so forth, but what deserves to be called religion
is certainly not disappearing, and in fact, I think
you see today. Many people and groups are looking
for uh, a kind of return to religion. You
see this in the right-wing movements in Europe and
in the United States, for example, you know, a
new interest in um more authoritarian forms of religion.
It's interesting here in the United States, young men
are, are keen to get involved with Russian Orthodox
Church. Which is quite unbelievable. I mean, very few
sociologists would have predicted anything like this 2030 years
ago. But then on the other hand, you have,
you know, more overt secularists like Dawkins that we
mentioned and you have people like Richard Rorty, for
example, who said, you know, in the 80s that
I think there's a good reason. To see people
coming to understand that we should get rid of
religion. That we ought to get rid of it
just as we ought to become adults. It was
about maturity for Rory to become a mature human
being, so you just have to leave this behind.
I think that that view is um probably less.
Often expressed today, that people have more respect for
religion and they just don't see religion as Childish
in the way that people tended to see maybe
30, 40 years ago, this kind of very robust
secularism, I think. Is weaker today than it has
been. Right.
Um, SO this is something that you've already touched
on a bit earlier, but do you think that
the conflict that, uh, certain people say is inevitable
between religion and secularism more if we want to
just reduce it to the epistemology between science and
religion? Do you think that that is really inevitable?
I think it's inevitable if you take the Dawkins
view and you construe religion as some sort of
epistemic pursuit of truth. For certainty, if you do
that, which I think is a complete misunderstanding of
religion, I mean I think so many people have
shown very successfully that this is not what religion
is all about, but if that's your understanding of
religion, um, then I think that the conflict between
religion and secularism is always going to be inevitable
because, uh, Uh, Then they seem to be competing
over the good of truth, the good of central,
important truth. For example, on that view, there will
always be these competitions over, Um, the emergence of
humankind, for example, on the, on the one hand
you have secularists who believe in Darwin and Um,
And biological, um, development and on the other hand,
you have religious people who are going to believe,
you know, that human beings were just created at
some point, you know, whether it's 6000 years ago
or 600,000 years ago, um, but they wouldn't believe
in natural selection. But this is a marginal view,
and I don't think it's a very common view.
So if you take a more a more reasonable
view and you say, well, they're actually not really
in competition, and I don't see the conflict as
being so inevitable. I think it's always going to
be, there's always going to be conflicts between different
types of morality and different kinds of moral systems
that spring from. Secularism and religion, right, but I
think, um, there are ways of conducting dialogue, and
many philosophers nowadays are interested in how to conduct
this dialogue. Even the Pope or the recent popes
have been interested in these kinds of dialogues. They've
been interested in ways to translate religion into more
secular terms for use, for example, in politics. This
is central to both Charles Taylor and. Especially Jurgen
Harbor Mass, I think there are problems with the
idea of translation. Uh, I mean, if you are
religion, religious, and you're asked to completely translate your
terms into a secular register in order to use
it, for example, in parliament, then, well, what's left
of your religion? I think there's all clear limits
to translation, but I nevertheless think that translation is.
Necessary. You see this for example in debates over
abortion. I mean, uh, religious people are going to,
to some extent, uh, translate their, uh, terms to
make their views justifiable within the, the secular, uh,
uh, settings of, uh. Modern politics, for example, although
they may have a principle which is religious, uh,
they are going to have to, uh, add other
arguments and other terms to this fundamental religious principle
that they're using.
Right, so we're about to start talking about how
each of the philosophers whose work you explore in
your book approached religion and what they tried to
do with it, but what do you think that
philosophers from Kent to Nietzsche tried to do with.
RELIGION more generally, I mean, I know that earlier
you mentioned that they have, or at least most
of them have criticisms of religion, particularly from a
more rationalist perspective, but you also said that it
seems that they were trying to rescue. Some aspects
of religion that manifest socially to apply them to
a more secular context. I mean, were those the
main things they were trying to do with religion,
or are there also some other common themes that
run from Kent to Nietzsche?
Yeah, I think um the way people have traditionally
approached the philosophy of religion in the post-Kantian tradition.
Has been to say, well, look here, we have
some interesting um attempts to understand religion and we
have some interesting attempts to Criticize religion, of course
it's very famously in the Critique of Pure Reason
in which there's a whole chapter devoted to a
critique of, uh, the proofs of the existence of
God, um, but I add, uh, a dimension to
this, and this is the dimension of rescue. I'm
not saying that these philosophers necessarily try to Kind
of rescue religion in its totality or rescue Christianity
in its totality, but I'm saying that they're trying
to rescue certain dimensions of religion, and this dimension
I've already touched upon, I mean they have to
do with um, Uh, questions of meaning, um. Uh,
HOW to stave off different nihilistic forms of skepticism
against conceptions of value or conceptions of moral bindingness,
um. There are some really, I mean, Hegel is
the one who gets closest to actually trying, at
least nominally to rescue Christianity. But we can get
back to Hegel in a, in a little bit,
but um the old philosophers are much more skeptical
of religion and only want. To rescue something which
is. For them expressible in more, well, in more
secular terms. I mean Hegel also expresses religion in
secular terms, but he believes he can kind of
hold on to Christianity by reinterpreting Christianity in philosophical
terms. Right. So it's critique and rescue, which are
the kind of like the dual focus. That I
have on these philosophers.
So let's start with Kent then, which is actually
the origin of all of this. I mean, the,
the others that come after him are post-Kantian German
philosophers. So, uh what did he actually have to
say about religion?
Yeah, it's uh comes as a very interesting figure
and it's kind of a paradigmatic figure for me
in terms of this critique and rescue. Strategy, um.
He came quite late to religion. He published a
book called Religion Within the Limits of Pure Reason
when he was very, very old, um, so it's
a difficult book to read. It, it has, there
are marks in this book of, uh, high age.
I think many people would say, uh, some complicated
passages and sometimes obscure passages. He had a religious
upbringing and people are experts on um. Point to
that, um, some people say, well, he actually was
a very secular philosopher. Other people say, well, actually
the religious impulse was alive in him throughout. And
of course he says in the introduction to critical
purism that he wants to save religion from freethinking
as he calls it. And he thinks that his
transcendental idealism can give him a path by means
of which he can do that. By distinguishing between
the world of um the natural necessity and natural
order and the world of freedom which escapes this.
World of mechanical necessary order, but in any event,
um, Kant in his moral philosophy, you know, he's
very focused on duty and the moral law, but
he's also interested in happiness and he has a
conception of the highest good. The summum bonum. Many
people who only read his uh groundwork don't really
get to the summum bonum because uh he doesn't,
he hardly refers to the summum bonum in the
groundwork, and most students of his moral philosophy only
read the groundwork and not the critique of practical
reasoning which the summum bonum becomes very central. But
the simum bonum or the highest good is happiness
insofar as or to the extent that it is
morally deserved. Some thinks that happiness, if it's not
morally deserved, can never be an unconditional good. I
mean you can be, you can have happy devils.
Um, IT cannot be unconditionally good that they're happy.
It has to be morally deserved. And he thinks
that ultimately we have a kind of duty to
promote this kind of happiness, and there's a hope
that comes with this kind of happiness. That this
kind of happiness is possible for us, especially if
we think of ourselves as morally deserving, then we
have a kind of rational reason to hope that
this happiness will be. For us And he even
toys with the idea that motivation in morality does
require a sense of This happiness as being possible
if we were to think that. Moral behavior just.
Tended or very often. Tended to just lead to
happiness to people who actually act on duty, unhappiness,
then it would be very hard to motivate ourselves
to act morally. And in a world that seems
very dark for morality, in a world that makes
Horrible man-created events like Auschwitz possible. Happiness seems to
be dealt a blow. Why even act morally in
such an evil world? What's the point of acting
morally? So context that is kind of like hope
for happiness is actually quite central to moral life,
we have to have that hope. And he believes
that for that hope to really have any kind
of real meaning, we have to believe in some
kind of just moral order, a moral order in
which there's a point in acting morally, in which
acting morally leads to good consequences. And for that
to make sense, he thinks that we have to
postulate as a pure practical postulate of reason that
there's a God that guarantees that vouchers for this.
Moral order. And he even thinks that we have
to postulate immortality. As moral agents, immortality as the
infinite possibility of moral striving to perfect itself and
to reach some sort of deserved bliss. Um, OR
salvation. So that's a, that's an extremely, um, one-sided
view of. Christianity. Kant thinks that this is what
Christianity was all about in the first place. Most
readers of Kant will say, well, this is a
moralization of religion, which is very one-sided, but it
is a way for Kant to rescue religion. To
show that religion is possible insofar as we postulate
freedom, the possibility of acting morally, um, thanks to
transcendental idealism. We're able to hold each other responsible
in the moral sense and hence these postulates of
God and immortality follow from that postulation of ourselves
as the moral agents. So he criticizes. The idea
that we can have any knowledge of of God,
but he thinks that with morality we have to
postulate the idea of God, so he rescues this
idea as a postulate. It's, it's interesting because um.
It's so different from Hume, for example, who really
deals Christianity, uh, blow after blow with his criticism
of Christianity as a set of epistemic beliefs. Yeah,
I remember reading about those ideas from Kent when
I read the Critique of Practical Reason, because it's
interesting that some of the what he calls the
anti-gomeies that he presents in the Critique of Pure
Reason, like for example, not being able to Know
whether God exists or not or whether there's life
after death or immortal life. I mean, actually, uh,
he vouches for the necessity of both of those
things from a moral perspective as he does in
the critical practical reason and other works. So, uh,
what was the Kantian compromise?
Well, just to pick up one thing that you
were saying right now, I mean, Kant goes very
far in arguing that even religious authority flows from
human moral authority. So he says at one place,
even in the groundwork, he says, you know, why
should we see uh Christ as a moral, uh,
authority? Why is he setting an example for humankind
and why should we try to imitate some of
his, I mean, we can never be Christ, but
you know, it's a long tradition of trying to
imitate Christ. Why would we even do that? And
he says it's not because Christ is himself. A
moral authority. It is because we No, we have
the standard in ourselves in the form of the
moral law, and when we apply the moral law
to Christ, we see that he is perfection, we
see that he is moral perfection, and this has
led people to say, well, actually, This is Kant's
atheism. He thinks that we have to come on
stage in order to make Christ a moral authority.
Uh, WHICH is fascinating. It shows how far he
goes in making religion a human, a kind of
addendum to the human interest in morality. I don't
think it makes him uh into an atheist, but
I think he pushes religious religion as far as
he can in order to set it on a
completely new foundation. And he does this precisely through
this, as you mentioned, the Kantian Compromise that he
draws, using his doctrine of transcendental idealism. He feels
entitled to be able to draw a distinction between
the world of science and you know, technology, the
world that we know from, from and understand via
Newtonian science, a world of necessary causal relations, set
that apart from a world in which we are
able to be moral agents, in which we can
attribute. Consistently freedom to each other. We don't know
that this world of freedom exists, but. We can
postulate freedom because We see ourselves as moral agents,
and we have the. Good reason as these moral
agents that we are to postulate freedom as the
condition. Of acting morally. And hence, uh, the idea
of God follows ultimately from seeing ourselves as moral
agents in this way.
So moving on to Hegel then, you mentioned earlier
that at least in your view among all of
the philosophers and intellectuals that whose work we're going
to explore here when it comes to the topic
of religion. Uh, YOU mentioned that, uh, in your
view, he was probably the only one who actually
tried to rescue Christianity itself. So, uh, tell us
more about that and what kind of approach did
he have to religion more generally.
Yeah, I mean you have the young Hegel, um,
who, um, is quite nostalgic, who seems to mourn
the loss of religion, and he seems to express
this mournfulness in a kind of nostalgia for Greek
classical religion to a large extent. Of course he
was a Christian, but many of these Christian friends
of his, people like Hilderin for example, and Schelling
and so on, even though they were Christian, they
were also interested in the Greek pantheon. And Hegel
in particularly was interested in this, and he felt
that this was a much more social form of
religion that we had lost in modernity, that is
glue that religion was for the classical ancient Greeks,
um, this element of social solidarity had been lost.
So he's, he was interested in trying to think
about ways to kind of resuscitate that in modernity.
He thought for a little while as a very
young man that if we could could transpose the
French Revolution to Germany. And do the French Revolution
in a way, in a kind of republican way
that could reconstitute communities in a kind of very
free. Manner Then perhaps we could restore some of
the sense of community and solidarity that had been
lost. But gradually around the turn of the century,
around 1800, roughly, he basically gave up that and
started to think that. This kind of nostalgia doesn't
make sense. We have to think. From the vantage
point of modernity, and the vantage point of modernity
is certainly not one in which we can rescue
ancient Greek. Uh, RELIGIOUS life. We have Christianity, but
Christianity is a dying breath. It has become subjectivized
for Hegel. It has become. Uh, ALMOST, as I
mentioned earlier, you know, a kind of lifestyle, uh,
style of expression in people like Yakubi, who he
sees as a kind of strange Christian nihilist. Who
thinks that Faith is just this completely subjective, uh,
uh. Involvement, you know, having no attachment to any
external form of expression. Mhm. Um, AND he saw
that as really too weak to in any way
to, to rescue anything like Christianity. He continued to
be a Christian. But he started to believe that
Christianity could be, could be given a kind of
religious, uh, I'm sorry, a, a kind of Uh,
philosophical expression and that's what happens in the phenomenology
of spirit in 1807 and then gradually in the
whole system that he starts to develop a little
later and that is expressed in this encyclopedia of
the philosophical Sciences that he writes, you know, in
the, in 18. 1314, 15, this vast encyclopedic system.
And there he thinks that Christianity can um Yes,
can be given a kind of full, um. Philosophical
articulation that can rescue all the important elements of
Christianity while disposing of the more mythological, uh, what
he thinks of as representational, not fully conceptual elements,
you know, so he thinks that religion is typically
kind of expressed in images. In various forms of
representations that are just authoritatively handed over to individuals
by, you know, by scripture and by priests and
so on and so forth. What we need in
modernity and modernity requires it is rational justification, and
he actually believes that his system can give a
kind of rational justification of it. And he toys
with the idea that the monarch state. In a
sense, it's an expression of what religion. Is fully
rationally articulated.
So, and then later, later on with philosophers like
Feuerbeck and Marx, compared to Hegel, and of course
we have to say here that Marx was very,
uh, Marx himself at least was very much influenced
by Hegel and in his younger years, uh, as
a young man, he was a Hegelian and there's
some Aspects of Marxism that where we can actually
see some Hegelian elements there, but compared to Marx,
how did Feuerbach's and Marx's approach to religion differ
from his? I mean, what was their social critique
of religion?
Well, I think they, they, they clearly, they, they
clearly continue the Hegelian project of, in a sense
to try to. Translate religion and kind of pull
religion down from its metaphysical pinnacle. Hegel already starts
to see religion in fairly prosaic terms. He believes
that religion will continue in churches and so on
and so forth, but it's not going to have
much of an authority. The authority of religion will
be for the philosophers to really understand in purely
conceptual terms. Um, Feibach holds what I call a
projection view. It's affiliated with Hegel's view. In that
he wants to conduct a kind of dialectical critique
of religion. He's, he wants to show that Religion
sets up. Oppositions that are ultimately false oppositions between
human life and divine life oppositions between Human love
and divine love and so on and so forth,
we project our ideals, ideals that are actually fully
human, onto some imagined super sensible realm. So we
have a certain conception of what love is. Um
We think then of love in terms of some
sort of perfection. We have some sort of view
of what would count as love in its fully
actualized state. And then we associate that with something
that exceeds humanity and exceeds full human grasp that
we can only hope for and that only a
god in a sense could ultimately vouch for. Same
with justice, for example, we think of justice and
we think of human justice, but then we also
think that there must be ultimately some sort of
divine justice that always exceeds what humans can bring
about in terms of justice. You know, we can
only have, we can only bring about limited justice,
but never absolute justice. Uh, WE can never fully
pay back, you know. The people, the innocents who
are, are dead, for example, who are killed, we
can never get them back unless there's an absolute
justice that can bring them back to us. So
hence we have this belief in some absolute justice.
We keep on projecting these ideals onto uh. The
super sensible, we say they cannot be sensible, so
they have to be super sensible, that's fundamentally Feibach's
view. And Feib's strategy is, I mean it's a
well-known strategy, he says, well, actually the genealogy of
these ideals are human, we can trace them back
to humanity. It's we who have had interest in
the absolute actualization of these ideals, and now it's
time to see that they are human, all too
human to use, uh, Nietzsche's, uh, expression. Uh, EVERYTHING
in Feuerbach is human. He is this radical humanist.
So We should try to create society in the
name of these ideals that have been falsely projected
into the beyond. The projection, projection has been a
form of um alienation. So religion is all about
alienation for for and uh overcoming alienation is something
that we can do. It is something that requires
um thinking and reflection. But it also requires a
certain kind of shift of social norms and maybe
an overcoming of the kind of society in which
these norms, uh, and these, uh, demands for actualization
are prevalent. If we can create a society in
which there's more solidarity, then the demand for, uh,
divine love becomes less pressing, press, pressing. If we
can create a society in which there's more justice,
then the demand for absolute justice may, uh, recede.
Uh, AT least to some extent. This was Frebach's,
um, kind of measured optimism. But Marx criticizes for
about for not really having a very sophisticated view
of how social change can bring this about and
even to really fully understand how these ideals and
why they're projected beyond. Have happened. Marx thinks that
this is fundamentally to do with the way society
itself operates. It's not. Mostly to do with self
misunderstandings, that's worry about things. It's to do with
society, so. Whereas Feibach believes in projection as the
kind of explanatory um dimension of religion. Marx sees
religion as ideology and famously says, you know, that
um religion is a form of opium. Yeah, it's
an ideology. It's an opium for the masses, he
says in his most famous, uh, statement about religion.
Religion makes us feel good even though we shouldn't
feel good. It creates a kind of conciliatory glow
that's cast upon society that makes us forget injustice.
Because we believe that there is justice in store
for us in the beyond in heaven. So we
start to accept what shouldn't be accepted. That's the
ideological function in Marx and Marxists this as A
social function. And since it is a social function.
Ideology that is, it can also be overcome socially
and therefore the critique of religion should be a
social critique and not just merely um you know,
a critique of self-reflection. Or or a form of
self-reflection, I mean. Mhm
So, er, when it comes to Nietzsche, how did
he approach religion, and I mean, one very interesting
thing about N Nietzsche is that he. I mean,
in a sense, didn't spare anyone from criticism because
he had harsh criticism or harsh critics of religion,
but he also criticized at least some aspects of
the Enlightenment and associated, for example, also the ascetic
ideal with what scientists do and, um, I mean,
searching for or looking for truth with a capital
T. I mean that's. Uh, ALSO a form of.
Religious kind of or or religious like thinking. So,
uh, I mean, uh what, what do you have
to say about Nietzsche in terms of how he
approached religion approached religion, but also in terms of
his views of uh secularism.
It's a big topic because Nietzsche was obsessed with
religion, uh, from the get-go. I mean, he had
a very religious upbringing. He had plans to become
a minister. Um, I see him as both criticizing
religion and to a greater extent than all the
other philosophers in this tradition I'm looking at. Trying
actually to restore some genuine religious religious sentiments, um.
With regard to the Enlightenment, I mean, he adopts
some forms of Enlightenment critique of religion. He's quite
interested in the ways in which religion can be
oppressive, lead people to lead stultified, uh, lives. Um,
HE criticized the Enlightenment for. Um, Not being able
to really generate new values. Um, BUT he does
see the Enlightenment as successfully criticizing certain aspects of
religion construed in epistemic terms. So for example, some
of the criticism of religion like For instance, he,
he criticizes people who. ARGUES, for example, that if
God is good, then the world must be ordered
and then they. CONDUCT a logical fallacy, they say,
well, the, the world does seem order. There does
seem to be a lot of order in the
universe, hence there must be a, a good, good
God that stands behind it. That's a social fallacy.
Um There may be other reasons why it's ordered.
You cannot, uh, even though you believe in the
implication that a good God creates an ordered universe
that doesn't entitle you to infer from the order
of the universe to the good God. It may
just simply be that the universe is, is ordered
because of scientific. Realities. Uh, SO he, he, he
does embark on some of these kinds of enlightenment
criticisms of religion. Yes, the criticisms of the shortcomings
of faith construed epistemologically. Um But more interestingly, he
criticizes Christianity itself. He thinks that Christianity itself harbors
a kind of latent nihilism. And that is interesting
and very original. Christianity, um, brings about its own
ending. And its own ending is for everyone to
see, he thinks. Why? Well, Christianity is incapable of
creating. Values, it has had values and these values
have been central and centrally organizing for Western culture.
But these values are undermining, they're undercutting meaningful human
life. Because these values have to do with self-abnegation,
they have to do with um. Boeing before some
sort of absolute authority and undermining. Natural human vitality
and life and creativity and self-overcoming. Mhm. In Christianity,
we seek to Make ourselves as little as possible.
We seek to emphasize our lack of power, our
lack of glory, um, we see ourselves as, as
limited as possible, um. As, as the merely human
beings that we are, and we stake our hopes
only in salvation. And that's very, very self-undermining according
to Nietzsche. So he's interested in a form of
religiosity which can restore this kind of natural creativity
and self-overcoming and he heroism and social solidarity and
beauty. And that is the Dionysian. Kind of take
he has on the Um, Ancient Greek religion. It's
interesting that he stands in this tradition of being
interested, going back to the romantics, and like we
talked about how even Hegel was interested in this
in his youth. This Interested in interest in ancient.
Greek Religiosity, but. Nietzsche's Approach is different from each
other's in that he's so focused on Dionysus as
a figure. I mean Dionysus is a demigod. He's,
he's not a really a full god. I mean
he's the. He's the child of the tryst. Between
Seus and Sema. Semila, of course, was a. Human
being Mhm. Um, SO Dionysus is half human being,
but he has his followers, his mainance, these women.
And the following of Dionysis is truly transgressive. It's
socially transgressive, and Nietzsche thinks that they are in
a sense. Restoring a kind of sociality in which.
Well, I mean Bourgeois individuality is certainly fully overcome
in a in a kind of ecstatic, playful. Uh,
FORM of self overcoming, and that's what he in
a sense is toying with, you know. Can we
restore any of this kind of musical self-transgression in
modernity? He has some kind of wild idea that
Wagner's operas can do this. But he becomes disenchanted
with Wagnerian operas and gradually starts to believe that
that is not the truly dynasty and form of
religio religiosity that he was hoping for. He sees
sees too much of traditional religiosity and Christianity surviving
in. In Wagner. I was in New York a
couple of days ago to see Tristan and Isolde,
and I certainly felt that, yes, in that play,
the religiosity is certainly very um Obvious and the
Schopenhauerian dimension, the. Quest for. Redemption of all human
life. The overcoming of human life is very strong.
The libers taught in, uh, Tristan is very, very
central in this, uh, opera. The. Uh Idea that
in order to receive or attain full bliss, we
have to overcome human life and its limitations. Death
in a sense is the solution to the problem
of life. That's not Nietzsche's view, nature's view is
life is the solution to life. We have to
find ways to live life. Better and more to
the full than we do in rational modernity, and
that seems to be his kind of take on
religion. Mhm.
So since Nietzsche, how have philosophers and other thinkers
approached religion?
Well, um, the interest in religious, religious has certainly
continued. Throughout the 20th century in philosophy, although, I
would say that with the strong impact of um,
Pragmatism, naturalism, certain forms of very anti-metaphysical naturalist, uh,
sorry, analytic philosophy in the mid-twentieth century. These schools
of philosophy have taken very little interest in religion.
Uh, AND see religion as best as an object
of mere critique and been not very interested in,
in rescuing any dimensions of relig religiosity. I think
really. It's at the end of the 20th century
in which you see a real recurrence, and a
reorientation in philosophy, especially in German philosophy, but also
in some French philosophy. In which philosophers, philosophers have
started to return to religion and started to Take
an interest in how religion has actually shaped both
philosophy and modern culture and have started to do
some of the things that I'm doing in this
book, namely precisely to think about religion in somewhat
more positive terms, not just as an optical critique.
But as a. Source. For thinking about morality, thinking
about human life, thinking about the overcoming of nihilism.
Thinking about given solidarity and thinking about meaning in
ways that are more productive than what we often.
See in the more straightforward, rational and rationalist forms
of uh um. Uh, uh, PHILOSOPHICAL thinking. Mhm.
So I have one last question then, and earlier
when I asked you whether religion is actually on
the decline, you mentioned, for example, the fact that
er in Europe, at least it seems that many
young men particularly are turning toward more authoritarian. In
forms of politics and religion, and we also see
that for example among the so-called mega movement in
the US with figures like Trump and other people
from his administration and also his links to evangelical
Christianism, I mean, There are, uh, there's that link
between conservatism or conservative forms of religion and politics,
but do you think that even with those more
recent developments, religion has become more progressive over time?
Yeah, I think it's a mixed picture. I think,
uh, it certainly has become more progressive in many
different ways. It has the sort of if you
look for example at the Northern European Protestant churches,
I mean they have to such a large extent
basically endorsed modern culture. They don't even discuss abortion
any longer. They don't have worries about multiculturalism. They
don't have worries about people expressing their sexual identities
in ways that are non-binary, for example, any longer.
There are women priests, uh, in most of these,
uh. Uh, uh. Protestants, um. Churches and so on.
But on the other hand, I think nowadays, as
you rightly point out, I think there is a
strong, more reactionary trend, uh, um, strangely, perhaps. Among
young people and young men are interested, you see
in parts of the so-called manosphere, you see many
young people being interested in religion, and sometimes this
interest in is expressed in purely identitarian terms. These
are people who are quite desperately interested in being
able to express some form of identity that they
see as more binding and more traditional. And more
significant than Let's say consumerist forms of identity, you
know, they want something which has more oomph than,
than that. It's not enough to just buy a
pair of Levi's or have a pair of ski
or do skiing in the Alps or something. It's
about tying up with some deep identity. So it's
not that these men necessarily believe in some sort
of supernatural, super sensible God or some kind of
divine, but they feel very strongly that there's something
here that they ought to. Connected. And um if
I were to speculate, I think that this trend
may just probably just continue, especially under the influence
of AI that makes people perhaps Well, could lead
to an even stronger. Uh Even backlash, I mean
a kind of desperate need to express identity. I
mean, there's AI really is. Going to take over
more and more people's. Self-reflection, more and more of
their formation of a sense of identity, if you
keep asking AI or more and more often for,
Moral advice or lifestyle advice or advice about. Existential
types of belief. Well, I think you may reach
a point in which you're feeling quite lost in
this process and you feel the need to connect
to something which is outside of these forms of
information gathering and information imposing. And um What kinds
of political forms this will take, I think it's
for the future to see, but right now I
think We're certainly seeing a lot of reactionary politics
coming out of this. Just as this craving for
religion saw reactionary forms of politics coming out of
it in the 1930s, for example, you know, in
which totalitarian politics took on quite quasi-religious forms. Both
in, you know, more extreme forms of Marxism, but
also of course in fascism that took on clear
religious hues and forms in various ways, ways, and
which was clearly exploited politically along these terms. You
know, in the Nuremberg rallies, for example, that clearly
used religious, uh, uh, forms of, uh, expression in
order to gather people's, uh, gather momentum politically and
Make people subscribe and identify with this movement. So
it's dangerous to want to rescue dimensions of religion
in my view. But I also see that it
may be um worthwhile and interesting and useful in
if done in ways. That are morally acceptable and
that can align better with what we can recognize
as In my view, more liberal orientations in politics.
And that's also one reason why I'm returning to
this kind of post-content tradition because I think They
offer ways of returning to religion and rescuing elements
of religion that Do not. Just. Crash into this.
Difficult. I think deeply problematic form of political reaction
that we often see. Kant and Hegel and Marx
and even Nietzsche at his best, I think, are
trying to steer a different course, a course. Which
hopefully can be more compatible with modernity and not
as reactionary.
Right, so, um, the book is again after the
Death of God, Secularization as a Philosophical Challenge from
Kent to Nietzsche. I will be leaving a link
to it in the description of the interview, and
Dr. Hammer, uh, just before we go apart from
the book, are there any places on the internet
where people can find you and your work?
Um. I do have a website. They may just
search for my website. Uh, I do have a
temple. Uh, UNIVERSITY website as well, um, where they
can search for, um, my personal website. Um, SO
yeah, I mean, if people want to look up
a little bit more and get some more information
about the kind of work I do, then, uh,
yes, that's where they may want to look.
OK, uh, we'll include that in the description of
the interview and thank you so much for taking
the time to come on the show. It's been
a fascinating conversation.
Thanks a lot, Ricardo. It's been an honor to
be with you.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolatti, Gabriel Pan Scortez
or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas
Stinnik, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.